what's happening there reject nation
craig and john here today we are going
to continue moon night with episode five
today after that insane cliffhanger from
last week and before you ask nope sorry
koi zhandra will not be with us today
you let him explain it i know there's a
really good reason he couldn't actually
be here today unfortunately but he will
be joining us for the finale you better
be coynel you're watching this without
him being here that means we'll have to
step up our game today be just a
sharpness and be just as fast talking to
you guys if you can though leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell get notified when our reaction for
the finale is up as always full length
watch alongside sync with the time code
for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page along with a bunch of other
shows and i did want to mention too that
the real rejects podcast is up what
we've been doing currently is like for
the moon night for example we'll upload
the review portion of this video since
those are usually like 10 to 30 minutes
long yeah guys if you want like just
audio commentary version of us go check
us out over there anywhere where
podcasts are found
guys let's get into this and also thank
the damn prepper boys thank you guys
probably said this now
[Music]
hey guys just wanted to say that if you
normally don't stick around for the
discussion part after the reaction i'm
actually really proud of the discussion
that we had of this particular episode
afterwards so i heavily encourage you to
do so if you normally don't that's all i
wanted to say enjoy the reaction this is
all
you're [ __ ]
calm down
whoa
yeah
you told me that you were in a place
that was
oddly reminiscent of this office except
that it was in egypt right and that you
were with a
rhinoceros
you're right it was a hippopotamus
do you think that is
sense
or nonsense somewhere in between you
were talking to me about a boy
do you remember that boy you think you
could tell me about to have a little boy
looks like a film school light in the
back oh yeah i mean they always pay you
a lot of money in this place you're
really good i'm gonna set myself up
thank you doctor
oh boy
oh [ __ ]
uh-huh okay
here we go i only see one of them in the
mirror
[Music]
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist yeah ah like the
ancestral plane oh
the ancestral plane they flat-out
mentioned it
she been through wakanda right through
these doors for example we go through
here there's gonna be a bunch of
patients and there's crawley probably
about to yell
well done well if your heart's balanced
in life then you will spend eternity in
paradise
the field of reeds but uh before we get
there i've just got to do a quick little
oh boy
[Music]
she's weighing our hearts on the scales
of justice hmm
oh
nice what if they don't balance you get
thrown overboard
the dead will drag you down into the
duet kill the hippo steal the vote
[Music]
there's chaos in you yeah buddy why is
it moving like that i don't know
i do not have a card for this
this boat contains all of her life's
memories but my advice
get in there and show each other the
truth flashbacks and bring us jake
lockley yeah
i don't know it's the street you know
how many streets have you walked down
your whole life there's a cab in the
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
gotcha
they're all yours what do you know these
people
yeah i kept wishing i'd fail
and one of them would kill me instead
the healing ended up being a curse [ __ ]
you are not
helping our afterlife
[Music]
little mark what's your name oh hold on
there wait a moment wait wait a moment
this little mark running off to his bat
mitzvah
[Laughter]
mazel tove
[Music]
we'll eat later
boys
you're gone too long i got jj abrams to
be in this show man yeah
great cameo
latest gate is
mom said not to when it's raining
that'll be fine don't be a baby ain't
nothing man gonna happen today do we
wrong kid dead
oh
creepy
gotta face your traumas man this is all
your fault this is all your fault oh
boy wendy please
we just about to blow out the candles
now
[ __ ]
that's harsh
we'll do it just you and i this year
okay
can't have a birthday without your
favorite cake
you were always jealous of him i
should've known you would do something
like this
there's so many stairs in this place i
know it's bowser's staircase
[Music]
[Music]
origins turns out going awol in a fugue
state gets you discharged from the
military didn't have a ton of options
after that so i went work for hire for
my old ceo bushman
bushman called for no witnesses and i
couldn't live with that is that gotcha
hey that's that
red scarf
oh he didn't make it explains why that
color has been showing up so much
ghost of specter past
ah this music cool
this is so cool
what a waste
to be my final word against the evil
doers
your mind
i feel it
fractured yes
broken
most fascinating
damn
takes advantage of him
in exchange for your life
do you swear to protect the travelers of
the night
and bring my vengeance to those who
would do them harm
sneaky old vulture
as my
moonlight
[Music]
the first time we called them my moon
night and this year i think so yeah can
you send word to layla please help us
free conscious please tell it you have
to help us what the heck
cyrus is not going to like this hey
all those people die
it'll be all your fault no no no no no
you can't i
wow did you inject me with something
he's found a barrier here in his own
mind here that's insane do you think you
created stephen
to hide
from all the awful things you feel
you've done in your life or do you think
stephen created mark to punish the world
for what your mother did to you
fascinating
there can be no progress without
understanding
can you open up to stephen
[Laughter]
still needs a guide
right now
open this door
oh boy bloody hell
look at the scene of this place
but it's right out before months easy
wow
just scales knocked to stephen grant
action figures off the table even girl
has no fear
open the door right now
you're gonna learn
oh
no
not meant to see that that's the whole
point of you oh wow
well you want to remember the truth
that you had a mother that beat you that
made your life a living hell you're
lying just trying to upset me but you've
gotten to live
thinking that she loved you that she was
kind that she's still alive
oh
god
she's i speak to her every day what are
you talking about you're always leaving
messages no no no no no no no no no no
thank you no let me out let me out let
me out let me out
[Music]
[Laughter]
stephen i'm your doctor
you're a doctor i'm here to help you dr
harrow yeah is it
yeah look at that
wow oh you've really gone up in the
world haven't you
a little haircut
a little silly tash there
it's very
ned flanders yeah
vocally dokly after your mother passed
that's not true oh i'm i'm so i must you
say that again my mother is alive you
say that i can i will freak out i
promise i must be mistaken what do we
call it
let me just get to him no actually don't
do that uh hello mrs graham poor guy
steven's here he'd like to speak with
you
steven oh
i'm almost dead
oh
acceptance man poor dude
explains why he's saying such a horrible
person like layla
who abuses him yeah
it's just recreating
oh
[Music]
it's a trip this is a
[ __ ] trip oh no dude oh my god no
trip
damn
no i know i did it again but i don't
know i'm i'm looking down the street is
that even talking to his
just thought he was a call happening you
were just a child wasn't your fault
the gates
the gates of osiris come on dude that's
a good [ __ ] show guys
wow transitional shot
it's
phenomenal our journey's come to an end
i i cannot stop the inevitable i was
really rooting for you guys but the
unbalanced souls of the duat now must
claim yours oh jesus
[Music]
oh no
oh
creepy
oh ouch
mark
you've got this
that's i've got this too
yeah goddamn right
go to bat
swing away
oh yeah
boom
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
oh no
oh you gotta be [ __ ] me now
[Music]
it's like being frozen over in space
scales are balanced
no
don't let stephen go
don't keep the chaos
[Music]
is this house
is he picking fruit over there
[Laughter]
and the adventures are showing up
[Music]
[Laughter]
just one moon
almost almost done crescent
waning crescent
wow we're an episode yeah it's pretty
beautiful
that's one process
yeah
i love that they didn't shy away from
just going full on psychological
inversion you know
psychological warfare is that the first
time i've really explored the uh abusive
mom angle it feels like it released in a
way that feels like focal you know yeah
well it's a fascinating way they're
handling this because you know most
mediums would do the thing of
there's still three there's still three
phases
who's that other sarcophagus yeah most
mediums would do the angle i'll just
commit to the whole thing that it's
steven's a made-up personality in his
own mind it's just there's a coping
mechanism the fact that that soul is
there in the underworld the afterlife
shows that that soul is very much real
both souls are very much real both
people are very much real and it's a
really fascinating way to do it
oh damn i thought we were yeah i know
bastards face your bachelors you
bastards
how could you
god yeah let's talk about it all right
guys i really feel like this is gonna be
the best discussion we've ever had
thank god coy's not here to ruin it for
everyone christ talking so fast you
can't even hear the points like we don't
need you just shut up oh you're shut up
that you read this isn't the time coin
replace
um
no i'd like to be totally frank like
this this hits all the cylinders of
everything that
i particularly am very much gravitated
towards in any medium no matter what it
be comic book show or whatever i'm this
is
if
i my passion in life is actually writing
and if you've ever read anything i've
ever written
i would this if there was a marvel
episode i would have written it would
have been this one except all the
egyptian stuff i wouldn't know what to
do with that but all the other things
i'm like yeah that's like my jam right
there that's what i love and that's the
stuff i love
and it's cool watching this and like my
thoughts just started
firing because i start seeing all this
like connective tissue of what they're
doing with this character with these
traumatic wounds of
of guilt
and shame
and
watching how the recreation of certain
things happens with like with the
psychological recreation meaning
you attract you know um
people or
events situations
that basically regurgitate those exact
feelings and
it's like i was thinking about the
situation with layla how she's not like
mark's mom you know that old cliche of
you know you date your parents or
something like that especially if you
have unresolved issues with them you you
attract someone who that would like it's
like you would think you'd be in an
abusive relationship or something like
that right
and
what what i found fascinating was the
last time we saw laila
was her blaming him for the death of her
dad
and
how she then abandons him or like
doesn't abandon him but is rejected and
turned like it's obviously not going to
be the same from here on out and that's
a very different circumstance
versus when
he his brother died and his mom blamed
him for that and held that against him
so it's a fascinating parallel to end it
on on that exact note despite the fact
that the
relationship dynamics are very different
between them
so uncovering that package and when i
think what they're doing with harrow
is
the the psych ward hero dr hero
the one comic reference i could i could
pull is that at one point mark's dad
does take him to like i believe it a
psychiatrist or a doctor some doctor who
specializes in this because he discovers
that he has a split personality or has
d.i.d
or something of that effect
and
you know they say that this hospital is
in chicago where mark is from
and so i think this is a projection of
that doctor
that he was speaking with so this is all
like childhood
traumatic wounds and watching how that
ripple effect has carried over into his
entire life
so i think it's just really like
awesome [ __ ] yeah
it really is and they created such
immersion and such
a well-blended psychological mind-bender
but with you know a good amount still of
wonder and you know mcu magic around the
periphery and it's cool because it's an
episode that has so much to do with all
the circumstances that have happened up
until this point
and some of those people and yet it it
absorbed me to the point where i wasn't
even really thinking about the other
episodes or or you know connecting
specific references it was it was a
wonder and a joy and and you know it
even despite it being sort of painful to
dive in so headlong to these characters
and to make it so that i feel like
that's just a good dramatic device is
you know in order to figure out
whatever mcguffin or or you know ticking
clock is at hand we need to dive into
ourselves and we need to clear some sort
of trauma or confront something or move
some kind of emotional baggage and
they've
really made steven and mark and and
everything that that entity is really
gripping and really touching and really
poignant and resonant and like i think
in the in the comic that this draws
heavily from you know like steven is is
an imaginary friend at first that
becomes
you know the the other personality and
here i thought it was so such a
wonderful choice to make his origin the
the kernel of the moment that he becomes
here is portrayed as a direct kind of
response to this this horribly painful
event
and i i love that you know i mean they
were talking about the show as being
heavy and i think it's easy to associate
that with violence and even in the
ending moments where you see mark you
know sort of you know in that origin
that we'll get to surely in a moment you
know where he's on the steps underneath
the conscious statue like you know
there's that blood and it is you know
harsh again it is stark but i i love
that the heaviest stuff is the emotion
of all this and and the exploration and
the and the confrontation
of just how harsh of a life this guy has
had and how
you could point at any one of these
moments and go that's the origin but
they're all kind of the origin of what
is right now yeah and i think that was
really beautifully handled in an episode
that again you have this
you know sort of transition at the end
of episode four and you spend the entire
time you know sort of oscillating within
the realms all anchored by this this um
what do they call it you know they like
the construct to organize all that you
know for your mind and making that be
this hospital i thought it was it was
like this you know the promise of marvel
on disney plus or tv or whatever it's
like movie caliber
television and i felt like that was
absolutely what this was you know almost
100
well i think what this episode did is
similar to what wanna vision did as well
you know it's interesting when you look
at like the netflix model where was
usually like episode four was when they
would decide to do like a whole origin
tale yeah of how they got their powers
and i noticed what they do with their
origin tales here
that
one division did it i think close to its
final episode if i'm not mistaken
and then this is the penultimate episode
as well
is it's not really about an origin tale
of how they got their powers it's more
of an original of why they are the way
they are yeah as people and i think
that's a way more fascinating
deconstruction
of our of our characters because you
have two characters here you're
deconstructing who are part of the same
body part of the same entity yet the
goal for both of them is to each get to
a stage of acceptance you know they all
have they both have a different form of
denial like mark seems to have
a logical understanding of what he's in
denial of but it's the feeling that's
the heart that's the things he can't do
is like he knows up here you know like
that's like a lot of the time i'll talk
with individuals who have um i'll talk
about if i have patience or something
i follow and talk with my followers
about their psychological problems
absolutely and a lot of times you talk
with people and even for myself uh a lot
of times i might logically know like oh
yeah i know why i'm the way i am but the
key to uprooting that is sometimes
depending on like what type of
therapeutic process you're going through
is you have to relive those memories uh
not to dwell in it but to accept it and
so you could let it go
and that's what they're doing here but
just on a pure visual medium and where
it's very physical of diving directly
into it and it's both of them having to
face the reality like stephen is the
opposite he feels he's very he is
vulnerable um
but up here is where it's all blocked
whereas with mark his up here okay for
the for our podcast listeners
up here meaning the mind is where he's
all blocked whereas with mark uh in the
mind he knows but in the heart he can't
feel he he has to fight against the
feelings so i think that's where the
balance i mean it's one way to interpret
it i feel like the balance comes down to
the mind and heart having to coexist as
one the logic and emotion both learning
to
be in harmony with one another where
stephen represents like a different
emotional side of him and mark is all in
the head
about it and so i love that and so
that's where the crack happens on the
day of the funeral just that inability
to to rectify the two yeah it's it's
it's powerful it's powerful powerful
stuff and i love how even in the psych
ward quote unquote uh whatever you want
to call it is that
there
even dealing with
dr harrow that's still a form of them
repre like every time they get closer
yeah to
uncovering and facing truths they go
back to that room
and they go back to the room so they
still need the guide they still need the
push uh they still that's still them
both of them fighting against the truth
because even stephen when it comes time
for his big truth the thing he can't
face which is the death of their mom
uh he fights against it and escapes you
know
so
it's it's a neat
correlation
as to what's happening to get the answer
to of like this is mom real what's going
on there you know
and and it is it's interesting the
choices of the female interest they've
had with
the and i don't know how intentional
this is
um
there is something similar in appearance
and look that they've done with the
first person that's asked out who i
still think is jake lockley uh in the
first episode to ask out to dinner you
know get meat get the steak
and layla and the mom they all are kind
of similar in appearance i don't mean
that in like a racial stereotyping way i
honestly don't know the racism of the
other two of the act i don't know the
race of the act of actors uh but there
is a likeness that does kind of reflect
who his mom is
at the same time so it's it is it is
like very psychologically poignant
and then of course you know all you get
all the cool
egyptian stuff yeah
two of
going to like i i kept i i did start
there's only one point where i started
getting pulled out going is is doctor
strange going to do this because you see
those like zombie characters in there
yeah yeah
yeah you're like oh they're gonna look
the same they're gonna have the same
design is this what what this is yeah
are we going there over time is it time
for the mcu to break through
and become an alternate personality of
this show well i you know that's what
they look like what is that called the
because you know
what the duat
the the sea of the the
dead souls
well you see it's it's an interesting
prospect because if you're looking at
mark specter as as just a pure
individual
you know or or like most
movies and shows will take the approach
of
you are a thing i have created i have to
let you go so i can be in harmony with
myself and be one complete
where i don't feel like the show is
going that path especially because it's
penultimate i don't think the show is
going that path i think
that
the the bigger realization has to be
presuming because where the wrench gets
thrown in here is like let's presume for
a moment
that him being at the field of reeds at
the very end is indeed
real
you know or is it still part of his mind
uh i'll go off the presumption that it's
real now
it's like how does he get out of there
because he has to come back
you know there's a pen ultimate episode
he has to come back to earth you know
join forces conscious stop hero you
gotta do all that [ __ ]
i don't
i don't feel like the answer though
with the unique approach with this i
don't think the answer is to put steven
away
you know yeah
it doesn't without without going too
much into you know the spoilery comic
book things i i feel like they're going
towards something that will probably
mean yeah that these characters will
continue to coexist in mark's mind and
if anything i wonder if they're going to
bring in that theme of leaning into that
chaos in your heart and mind that kind
of comes up in the book
because that i could see as a clear
route of you know perpetuating this
character and and making it a thing that
can easily keep on going and two i feel
like maybe at the end then we might get
a jake lockley tease and as much as
we've sat here and been like where's
jake uh i've at least as of this episode
really enjoyed the choice or or i feel
it rewarding that they kept it to mark
and stephen and had that be such a lucid
interplay and two like i'm excited to go
back through the show and just pick up
all the different like the i have to
imagine there's an expert kind of
correlation between all the different
little visual motifs or faces of people
who show up or you know it's like you
know it's like the scales popping up or
you've got the the uh uh
steven grant like toys and things like
that that show up and all these
different things
um
but two just like i loved what ethan
hawk was able to do here too because
i enjoy this version more than i enjoy
hair uh arthur harrow to be honest
because arthur herrera becomes a little
one-note comical the further you get
from the main plot the more i'm like i
love what ethan holland he's like he's
good on the mortal plane as you know
this this
pseudo avatar of amit or whatever but
him as
dr uh harrow i think has been terrific
to watch because you know when you're
removed from the circumstances of the
plot it also it's like you have that to
inform your perception of the
performance and so it adds to this whole
off-putting uneasy uncomfortable
like it the episode does manage
something i think is really hard which
is kind of translating what a sort of
insanity or at least
being i have to imagine at least the way
they portray it here you know this
inter-clashing of personalities has to
be sort of jarring for a person and you
know having so many loops where you have
to question your own sanity it's very
jarring and i thought they captured that
really well and i loved how you almost
have ethanol at the center of it with
just the most warm and and beautiful
presence that becomes benevolent at
times like it almost seems like he
legitimately does
get stephen at least to that point like
that whole scene with the phone i
thought was really beautifully handled
and when he finally holds it himself and
hears the dial tone like i thought that
was a beautifully supportive scene
between the two of them and yeah like
it's it's he
harrow you know for whatever his plan is
on actual earth you know i feel like
could be one of the most memorable mcu
villains uh to me anyway
partly because of all this stuff is like
man that is a character whether or not
you know like the main plot stuff is all
that satisfying in the next episode or
just amounts to we got to vanquish them
we did it you know well i think with dr
harrow it
it's so perfectly suitable to have the
project like marx and steven's own
projection
of the doctor i mean i'm under the
assumption that
you know mark spector did have a doctor
at one point in his life and that's what
we're dealing with they gave enough
clues indicating like where this
hospital is located and a very specific
a very specific name of the hospital
like it sounds like this is
an actual part of his past
to have the villain
be uh to have the doctor
have the face
of the the villain on earth arthur
harrow because
that doctor for someone who is in that
much of a denial process
considers them a threat
to
their well-being because they fear
having to go inside
and
twist the reality that they have made up
in their own minds like this is the
reality that i'm not talking about like
specifically a person with d.i.d i'm
obviously not
that educated on specifically that
subject but on a basic human level um
yeah i would i think that's what they
are they're doing with him so i think ha
because i kept wondering why choose
ethan hawk to specifically be him
because
when you're in a situation like that you
view that person like the villain
especially because i imagine
that mark did not voluntarily go see
this doctor i imagine that he was sort
of you know as a young person was put
there
or to to you know be studied or to try
to work through this but didn't emit
himself at the age of a consenting adult
yeah absolutely as the sort of last
resort we're just going to put you here
and that's probably going to make the
whole thing seem colder and more
adversarial yes and
without having like of
parental figures to truly trust i think
that that bleeds over to in the previous
episodes like you see it here with
conscious taking advantage of him
manipulating on his weak emotional
weaknesses because it was a cool
correlation of how he's physically he's
literally physically dying but he
doesn't prey on that he's preying on the
internal weaknesses of mark spector at
that moment
and even with layla in the psych ward
she takes advantage of him as well you
know
so it's it's like he
yeah i i i wouldn't say like the mom
like takes advantage but in a way she
does because she imposes all blame for
what happened to the dead son the
brother on
her and it's cool that what they've done
with stephen is he's not just a coping
mechanism he's also a void
for he fills the void for what
losing the brother left behind he found
a brother there so i i think what mark
has to get to
is a point
of realizing like stephen you're not
a separate person you're not
not me yeah i am you as well and and
like they have to and like steven was
accepting that on the boat he was
accepting that you see him doing that
like if i i can do so that's why that's
where he gets the badge able to like
mess up some of those um
dead lights you know what they are
i thought that was a cool effect just a
quick sidebar like of all the things
i've seen in these shows and movies to
create some fun pulpy violence without
it being like gushy i thought the whole
like sand zombies thing was great looked
wonderful yeah it did
so yeah i mean i think this is a an
amazing ass episode i really love this
one um yeah quite a lot i thought it was
all going to be about who's the hippo
and how are we uncomfortable
who are you just tell us already but i
called the boat you did called the boat
called the boat man you are observant
you're a good cinephile called the boat
you did man i didn't think it'd be on
sand but i called the boat
okay the little pirates just sprinkled
it i couldn't help but think a little
bit about pirates during a couple of
those exteriors but we also got the
ancestral plane shout out that was cool
yeah that was nice it seems like the mcu
has like some version of uh
i don't know some dimensional
underworld
like there's pocket world the pocket
dimensions of their under it's not like
you know it's not like traditional
christianity which is earth heaven hell
yeah yeah
you know one of the three you like yeah
yeah and it's not just egyptology it
seems like the how they embrace this is
there's like pocket dark dimensions or
something else you know afterlife
dimensions it feels like the metaphysics
is informed by whoever's perspective is
experiencing them yeah like the
ancestral plane within black panther uh
wherever
freaking thanos saw
uh gamora in infinity war
after uh being on it's like a
four-minute four beerus and voldemort
yeah after being on vormir and then here
it's like they have and it seems like dr
strange will probably explore more of
that too
yeah um
yeah this was a phenomenal episode
that's phenomenal and i'll end up with
this
i have not seen last time i felt this
way was with the netflix shows um
i
really hope
that
when emmy season rolls around and i
don't really give a [ __ ] i rarely watch
a war i only watch the officers this
year because i was in a voting pool and
i just wanted to just hang out with
friends drinking and i
was fortunately it was the best option
we got the slap yeah actually it was
amazing um
i
i really do hope that they consider
oscar isaac because he is incredible in
here he's absolutely incredible it's not
easy what he has to do
and kudos to the because i can get
distracted from time to time of
you know
i rarely become aware
that there
that
there was a time with any scene with
mark and stephen that
oscar isaac had to do is take his mark
and then he had to do a stephen and then
they had to splice it together
i rarely become aware
that they had to film it that way i
usually am just so pulled into the
performances and what's going on
that
i don't i don't question it i don't
think about it i'm just buying two
completely different people and then
when you have scenes like post funeral
when he shifts in and out it's like it's
not
only impressive it's
like i'm not even i don't know how to
put in a word this is so it's just such
damn good acting and he knows how to
embody both and he can switch in and out
of both characters oh yeah
insanely well it's incredibly lucid yeah
yeah for sure and now i just hope that
next week they can really like i hope
they stick the [ __ ] plan i don't
really hope they do because it's funny
because like this is an episode where
where it's like you know whatever led
before it and whatever is happening
after it i was like so
like this is one of my favorite all-time
just episodes of the mcu thus far and
yeah now i'm just like there seems like
there's a lot left to do though like in
one episode i am a little nervous if
they can stick the landing and not just
turn into because it seems like it's set
up
to become the problem that some of these
things fall into which is big battle
episode yeah that's what i don't i need
to get to conscious become moonlight i
want it to be a bunch of chaos nowadays
and then have like all plot and and
little like you know yeah i want to
carry some of this juiciness into that
next episode and to really feel like you
know the the all the elements because
you know you start out with more of the
fun and the mystery and then you get
into the deep psychological and i hope
that the last episode combines both yes
you know
yes
it's
it's neat when you think about the
character of mr knight in the comic too
of like a badass detective in a way yeah
you know whereas like moon knight is
pretty accurately portrayed uh via
through mark spector here
uh when you think about mr knight and
how different mr knight is
here versus the comic
where he's much more comical but that
goes to accentuate the psychological
association of
embodying
a personality
that is like fantasy fulfillment because
that's what stephen grant is yeah he's
an embodiment of fantasy fulfillment and
[Music]
and uh you know right down to the name
being pulled from
some movie that apparently young mark
spector was obsessed with no one's
last movie though
yeah dr grant and it's funny because dr
grant just would look like layla's dad
in the comic whatever her actual name is
that i'm blanking on right now in the
comics but yeah guys
marlene i think yeah i wanna say whitney
but yeah i think you're right whitney
the name bushman bushman not frenchie in
the frenchies on the phone
yeah i think that i think that's all
that's going to be i think decamp will
come in later maybe but but he says
bushman is his partner
hmm
and called that too and the new
rockstars breakdown we've only really
just brought her up that and like loves
buschmann
[Music]
how do you feel now um probably don't
even notice
all right guys thank you so much for
being here keep a lookout for our finale
reaction uh coy you're not missed at all
you can rot in hell yeah i hope you've
fallen too much
sucked down into the sun i hope you're i
hope you're doing miserably right now
never make it to the field to read and
yeah we'll catch you guys soon thank you
so much for being here
but let's shout out some patrons
josiah
i am maria pendley you're the one for me
nmb randy you taste like candy bane
jimmy burns was the name of the guy in
the mummy who got his tongue ripped out
in his eyes alan ling you make my heart
sing logan burton unbutton your shirt
eric conn's 39 i'm sure your ass is fine
ooh
it's cousy cousy quit your fussin
justin smith
kill phil
eider i'm kidding there's a bear in the
garage
nick
xylophone
juan longoria i hope i never bore you
gail the holy grail ferguson jaren
wanner
can get angry like bruce banner marvel
reference stifling already that is
literally what i'm saying
stiff cliff rodriguez chris with the
beautiful smell and piss busting i'd
leave her for alex bieber
master t with the beautiful smelling p
john the goat seven don't pee on my face
pseudonymous entity
pee-pee
ladies and gentlemen i give you
olivia delgade
thank you guys so much to pledging into
our patreon your support means the world
i mean it and uh
hopefully we see next month love you and
stay sexy
yeah yeah you perverts
[Music]